-What defines a home, really?
Is it just
four walls and a roof?
Or is it
something more than that?
I can tell you that, for me,
home is where my wine fridge is.
[ Spectators mumbling ]
Now, I've personally
never been unhoused,
but there was one summer where
they were doing construction
on our New York home,
and I had to stay at The Plaza.
At the end of those three weeks,
I felt like I was getting out
of Shawshank.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Maya Rudolph.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from her new series, "Loot."
So, you are married
to a billionaire, Adam Scott.
-Yes, Adam Scott was my husband,
who's a very powerful
businessman,
one of the richest men
in the world,
and then we get divorced
and I end up with $87 billion.
This is not real life, guys.
This is the show.
Don't get confused.
-Yeah.
And then, you know,
she's been with him
her whole life,
like since their 20s,
helped him build the company.
So now she's trying to find
meaning in her life
with $87 billion.
-There --
You shoot in a mansion.
-Oh, yeah.
We shot at "The One."
Have you ever been in a house
that has a name?
-No.
-This house was called The One.
-Wow.
-And it was -- I think it was
listed for $500 million.
And it was pretty insane.
-Yeah. For $500 million,
it would have been really funny
if you were like,
"And it's like, 'Eh.'"
-"I mean, I've seen better."
It was -- Like, the first day,
we shot at the indoor pool,
and I was like,
"This is pretty cool.
There's an indoor pool
in here, huh?"
-[ Laughs ]
And then --
I feel like
I just heard Shoemaker laugh.
And then I went outside,
and there were four other pools.
And then I went upstairs
to the master bedroom,
and there is a pool off the
balcony of the master bedroom,
but it's see-through.
So if, like, you want to watch
your lover swim --
Like, "Do the backstroke,
sweetheart.
Do me a favor."
Get me a cup of coffee and do
the backstroke, sweetheart.
Then do the breaststroke,
sweetheart.
Alright, now
just do the dog thing.
Paddle like a dog."
-The dog paddle.
-What is it? Oh, dog paddle.
"The dog thing."
-You had all the parts.
-I know. I gave up.
-"Do the dog thing.
Paddle like a dog.
What's that called?"
Dog paddle.
-It's called the dumbwaiter.
It's called the dumbwaiter.
-You also got to work with
animals in this, some alpacas?
-I did.
It was not my first Alpaca,
which know is a big surprise,
because when
you're in comedy, apparently,
you work with
a lot of strange animals.
-Yeah.
-Guess who I met this morning.
-Who'd you meet this morning?
-Trumpet, the Westminster
Dog Kennel champion, the winner.
-The bloodhound, right?
-Yeah.
-I have news for you.
He's hot.
-Oh!
-I have a little crush on him.
I went to pet him.
He's so lovely.
-Okay.
He's so sweet.
He smelled so good.
He's 4 years old.
-Uh-huh.
-And then he gave me his paw.
His paw was like this big.
But then he kind of
just kept climbing me.
-Okay.
-And I'm in love.
-Where -- I obviously
have a bunch of follow-ups,
beginning with, where do you
meet a dog like this?
-At the "Today" show, Seth.
On Grindr, Seth.
On Grindr.
-You have -- Yeah,
what's the new Grindr for dogs?
Oh, Dog Grindr.
-It's called Dog Paddler.
-Dog Paddler!
-If you look on Dog Paddler,
you can find --
-And you either
paddle left or paddle right.
-If you paddle right, you get
the champion of the
Westminster Dog Show.
He was
so beautiful and so gorgeous.
But he's --
A bloodhound, apparently,
is the only noi-- noise? --
Noise? Let me try that again.
-Yeah.
-A bloodhound is the only
nose that can stand up in court.
No other nose is allowed
to be listened to.
-Oh, wow!
So, legally, a bloodhound can go
in and point at a murderer.
-And say, "That's the guy
who murdered my wife."
-[ Barks ]
Do your best bloodhound,
how that would sound, if that --
[ Barking ] Ohhhh!
[ Barking ] Ohhhhhhhhh!
-So, this is interesting.
When you said
they're the only nose,
I assume that, like,
experts would bring them in
for other cases,
but it's only in a case
where their wife or husband
has been murdered.
-Where the the bloodhound's wife
was murdered.
-So they're only allowed to
testify if it's kin.
-Yeah. Like...
[ Barking ] "That's my cousin!
You killed my cousin!"
[ Laughter ]
-You showed up at "SNL,"
the season finale,
for our friend Natasha Lyonne.
And that was such a joy for me,
because she --
I feel like she embodies,
like, New York
and what's cool about New York
in the same way that "SNL" does.
-Agreed.
-And it just --
When did you first meet Natasha?
-I met her, actually, when
I first moved here to do "SNL."
She was one of my first
non-"SNL" friends.
And I think I was with Jimmy.
We were at the Mercer bar,
and this little person came up
to me and was like,
"Hey, you want to be in
a fashion show?"
And it was Natasha.
And her friend Chloe Sevigny
and Tara Subkoff
were doing their line,
Imitation of Christ,
and they asked if we'd be in it.
And I was really excited,
because I was like,
"You want me to be
in a fashion show?"
Funny thing is, they wanted me
to be the emcee
in the fashion show.
'Cause when you're in comedy,
you don't model
in the fashion show, Seth.
You're the emcee.
But it was so cool and fun.
But, like,
she's one of those people
that when you meet your people,
you find them right away.
We were instantly friends.
And, you know,
she spent so much time here,
backstage with us, hanging out,
and she's a part of those
early years for us.
So it was really meaningful
for her to be here
in what she called, like --
in her friends' house.
She had so much respect for it.
And she's so funny
and such a joy.
-It's also that thing --
'Cause it doesn't happen
all the time, because I think,
you know, understandably,
people have a lot of nerves,
and over the course of the show,
they find their way to joy.
-Yeah.
-She walked out
to do that monologue,
and it was just, like,
full joy, full excitement.
-Happy as a clam.
-Yeah. And it was great to
see you there,
as well, and Fred.
-It was so nice, yeah.
-And it's always nice
to have you here.
Thank you so much, Maya.
-Oh, my God.
Next time I come, we got to sing
"Gays in Space,"
'cause it's Pride Week.
-Yeah, it's Pride Week.
-Pride Week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can do -- If you want
to do a little now.
-I mean, if you want me to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What if I was like,
"'Gays in Space' in G, fellas."
Nobody knows it.
But I promise
I'll do it next time.
-Okay, great.
You guys, that's Maya Rudolph,
everybody!
"Loot" premieres on
Apple TV+ tomorrow.
We'll be right back with
Werner Herzog.